if you enjoy what we do here at The
Spectator you can subscribe to the
magazine and to our online content join
today and you'll pay just one pound a
week for unlimited online and app access
in your first year to subscribe to go to
spectator.com UK forward slash TV offer
[Music]
the Tory leadership contest could have
been an opportunity for the party to
refresh and have a battle of ideas after
over a decade in power instead it's been
rather vicious in points and although
this trust is far ahead the blue and
blue is worrying plenty of MPS but who
is having the better campaign to discuss
I'm joined by Isabel oakshaw and Patrick
o'flynn
thank you for joining spectator TV today
Patrick Elizabeth
now Patrick you've been uh very vocal in
your admiration for Liz truss's campaign
suggesting that she has steamrolled
Rishi sunac do you think there's any
hope for Rishi sunak at this point or do
you believe the polls are right and it's
pretty much a done deal
well I think it's a done deal I should
say by the way that I'm really was a a
kemi badenock uh Aficionado before that
was fashionable and I wanted her to win
but in her first choice a forced choice
between uh Liz truss and Rishi sunak it
seemed to me that she's much the best
choice I think she's run a more mature
campaign and rishi's inexperience has
really uh told I think it's been a very
Macho campaign from him almost like him
and Dominic Rob are doing a remake of
Top Gun as Maverick and goose and
getting their Cadets to Trash Talk uh
Liz and it's gone down very badly with
Tori Grassroots members that I speak to
and it seems to a lot of people that
that kind of Rishi was in in love with
the idea of winning and isn't really
Collegiate about the future of the party
and causing collateral damage in the
later stages of what's now for him a
hopeless pain
crikey
Isabel um you've written extensively
about rich you see like in the past and
in one article recently you said that he
was one of the most intelligent and
hard-working politicians you'll come
across how do you rate his campaign so
far
well um I thought Patrick's assessment
there was a little bit harsh to say the
least I mean if only it were a replay of
top gun Maverick at least it'd be a bit
more glamorous wouldn't it and I don't
think it's really fair to say that
sunak's campaign has been Macho I mean
I'm not quite sure what Paddy's basing
that on perhaps the early criticisms
that he was mansplaining and that he was
continually interrupting Liz truss I
think that the campaign teams corrected
that I was a big and have been a big
actual admirer of Richie sunac I think
his uh he's an extremely able uh
politician but I think where I would
agree with Paddy is in the inexperience
and actually I've been struck by the
sort of naivety of the sunat campaign I
said before all this started privately
to some of those involved in the sunat
campaign look the only way you're going
to have any hope in this is if you are
for one or two really significant and
totemic tax cuts right at the beginning
of your campaign that then squares off
that issue and they simply would not do
that because you know they say Rishi
genuinely doesn't believe that's the way
to sort of address the economic
difficulties that we're facing the
problem is that once he decided not to
offer any tax cuts and in fact actually
to sort of double down and own that and
say actually I'm standing on a a tax
raising agenda he had no hope whatsoever
in my view you know he basically lost
the argument before it had even begun
because anyone who has been in any room
with any conservatives over the last few
months know that that is basically all
they're talking about the need for tax
cuts Patrick I was speaking recently to
a supporter of Liz truss who's been
working on her campaign and they made
the point that you really need to focus
on the electorate in front of you the
mistake that Tori leadership hopefuls
can make is to worry about the one after
that so the general public in an
election and do you think perhaps Rishi
sunook has fallen into that trap
compared to Liz trust in a sense it
feels Liz truss's plans her policies
part of what Isabelle is saying are very
focused on their membership whereas
Rishi students I don't seems to be
talking to a wider audience
uh well I'm not sure if it's a wider
audience but it is a different audience
and you know he's been characterized
hasn't he as the archetype or uh Davos
man and he's clearly one plot it's from
leader writers on the times and The
Economist and and people uh like that
it's certainly true the the the kind of
wider electoral polling shows that tax
cuts aren't a great priority uh for the
for the general public compared to you
know four or five other more uh urgent
issues
um I think it shows that perhaps Rishi
sunak doesn't know the conservative
membership that well but I also think it
indicates an enormous sense of
complacency uh from him almost as if you
know some very senior people in the
conservative party backstage have been
whispering into his ear about him being
the the natural successor and you know
he came to believe that and got himself
in a lot of wrong positions not just
over not offering tax cuts but but being
seen to be the prime instigator of the
downfall of Boris Johnson which again
you know a more seasoned advisor might
have said you know you don't want to be
anywhere near that you know you should
Row in behind Boris now you know he I
think it went wrong for him the day
manira Mirza walked out on Boris and
Rishi sunak at a treasury press
conference said about their kierstama
Jimmy Savile Jive I wouldn't have said
it and yet didn't address the point that
KIA St armor had been really brutally
rude about Boris Johnson in the seconds
before Boris hit back so from rishi's
point of view you know Kia was elevated
and Boris was relegated and I think
since then a lot of uh core
conservatives have had it in for him
basically it's for what do you make of
this betrayal narrative there's uh
definitely getting some traction when it
comes to Richie sunac and this idea as
put out by some that you know healed
from the Betrayed Boris Johnson in and
some go as far as I don't think the
evidence for these supports say you know
here's the reason Boris Johnson is
um you know is is no longer prime
minister how does that square up to the
politician who you know you've studied
so actually I think it's a massive comms
failure on the part of Rishi sunax
otherwise very slick operation that
they've allowed that narrative to build
up and I think there are two things
going on here in the eye of the general
electorate which is as we've been
discussing uh the either Mr sunac seems
to be focused on
um actually it did him no harm
whatsoever to be seen as a man of
principle the one that wouldn't take any
more of this and put his put down and
said honestly I can't go on because
Boris Johnson had become a liability and
there were many reasons which we don't
now need to go over for the umpteenth
time why Boris Johnson had to go so on
that side to the general population I
think it's very likely that his decision
looked a pretty good one you know his
resignation letter looked like a man who
has integrity and wasn't going to just
stay in his job for the sake of it the
problem that he's has got in this
context is that the Tory membership we
now know a significant minority of them
are still Boris supporters and Boris
fans and we know this
um almost sort of numerically because of
the actual surprising amount of traction
that Lord krudus's strange and
interesting effort to get him uh back on
the ballot paper or to change the rules
for the party membership that has
actually amassed you know something like
13
000 you'll probably know the figures
better than I do supporters so there was
obviously a weakness there but but but
if he had combed it right if he had
actually presented this properly it
didn't need to build up as such a damage
damaging narrative as it has done
do you agree with that Patrick
well I I I'm not sure I agree now in
general that that Rishi is kind of more
highly thought of than his trust among
the electorate at large I think the last
few polls certainly I think the last two
perhaps you govern Redfield and Wilton
uh have actually showed that that she
does much better in match-ups against
kirstama now than he does so he clearly
he began the campaign with a marginal
advantage on that partly because of uh
just profile but that's ebbed away which
really tells us a bit more about what's
gone wrong with with his campaign and
again this trust could have could have
uh responded in kind to all the jibes
she could have raised his fixed penalty
notices Green Card his wife's non-don's
non-don status and indeed the Boris
betrayal narrative now she hasn't really
done any of that and I think you know
not necessarily that she's some kind of
angelic figure but she's not being put
under any real pressure by him since we
reached the last two in the campaign
that's right I mean in a sense she
hasn't needed to do any of that I mean
once he decided he was standing on a
platform of continuity and let's carry
on with the highest taxes we've had for
70 years she really didn't do anything
it needs to do anything else other than
say I'm not going to go down that route
that's it you know easiest campaign ever
and on that it's about do you think if
we go for what The Bookies currently
point to what will the polling points do
and we go along with the assumption that
right now it looks very likely Liz trust
will be the next prime minister part of
the reason they wanted to have this
contest over the summer to make sure
that uh you know to go to the members
was to allow for more scrutiny to really
test out the two candidates do you think
we've had that do you think Liz truss
has been tested in this campaign
well I don't think anyone's really
tested until they're in the job and this
is why we build we journalists tend to
build people up and then pull them down
once they actually get to their
destination I don't think that really if
what you're pointing at is should Richie
sunac pull out
um I I don't subscribe to that I think
that there's a process there's actually
fortunately for us all not that long to
go with that process now another three
weeks or whatever it is and I think look
they've all got to stick it out I do
feel sorry for the many young people on
his campaign who by the way aren't being
paid they're doing it for nothing you
know a lot of young people putting in
incredible hours and yes it's amazing
experience but they sort of have a
feeling of Doom about the whole thing
and we've got to carry on with this
charade for the next three weeks but I
don't think it would be the right thing
to pull the plug on it and there's no
sign that he's thinking of doing that
and Patrick is there anything that
worries you about prime minister trust
and from what you've seen so far we know
that she's your preferred candidate of
the two left
um but do you think in terms of media
where do you think her weak points are
well I I think she might be a little too
wildly thatcherite uh for the red wall
although polling shows that red wall
voters seem to prefer her uh somewhat to
Rishi sunac I don't think you know what
the red war was offered which won them
over at the last election by Boris uh
was a shrinking they didn't want a
shrinking of the state you know uh and
uh she is going to primarily use a kind
of tax cutting and therefore stand on
your own two feet uh response to the
cost of living crisis in effect
challenging people to create more wealth
and earn more money uh we're yet to see
what what's targeted support she might
do for older and poorer voters so that's
slightly worries but I think she's
demonstrated a toughness I didn't expect
from her and the key moment I think it's
not now in this walkover against Rishi
sunak but in the earlier stages
particularly there was a point where uh
Kenny Baden not came quite close to
eclipsing her as as the Challenger of
the right as the dynamic Challenger and
and we had the first TV debate I think
on channel four where Liz truss was very
very weak uh very one I just didn't rise
the occasion at all and she was in great
danger then but two days later
um I think was probably the ITV debate
on a Sunday evening she bounced back
really quite strongly and I thought that
took some guts and since then you know
she's done just enough every round and
the final two I just I think you know
she's faced some fairly hysterical
attacks from the sunac camp but nothing
that's really felt uh like it's going to
derail her and I think she's growing in
confidence and her media performances
are improving too albeit from a
relatively uh low base
it's about using Liz truss will make a
good prime minister
well let's hope so I mean agree with
Paddy that she's got better in terms of
presentation that was always the single
biggest weakness I thought she had you
know very uh sort of poor Communicator I
remember sitting through one of her
conference her conference set piece at
last at the last Conservative Party
Conference and thinking that I had never
heard a more poorly presented speech and
not only that the content was absolutely
dire so I do hope that since then things
have changed a lot like anyone can have
a bad day and she's certainly doing
really well in these televised debates
now
um so look I really hope that she's
going to be what we need you know
otherwise it's just going to be two
terms and the Tories are sorry I'm sorry
two years and the toys are out and
Patrick you made a really interesting
point just then about is Liz trust tooth
Thatcher out for the red wall and
because I think
at this point it would take quite a big
upset I think for people to start
thinking you know Richard said it has a
chance of beating her in the polls like
his supporters but of course if they
were here say everything is to playful
um but in the past week I think as it's
looked here and it's actually she gave
to the financial times especially you
know tax cuts no handouts you saw her
supporters try to row back a bit from
that saying there could be emergency
relief in the face of soaring energy
bills and but then again uh whenever she
is pressed on it is very clear instincts
are in reducing the tax burden and not
uh doing what she believes Richie sunak
is doing which is basically an imitation
Gordon Brown where you tax people and
then and then you just give them a
little bit of that money back
um and then you also have the windfall
tax now there's some talk today in the
papers of how that could be strengthened
and team Liz have completely hit back at
that they do not want to have a a
windfall tax that brings them more money
or to toughen that up because I think
it's unconservative so do you think
there is a risk that actually some of
these policies which are poll World such
as the windfall tax which Liz trasser um
and if her Chancellor is quasi-quartang
and are both ideologically opposed to
could lead to a backlash amongst those
red wall voters
yeah that's certainly a risk I mean you
you know she's always compared to
Margaret Thatcher isn't she or it's
thought to compare herself to Margaret
Thatcher and you know you could look at
the the early Jeffrey Howe budget where
he basically steamed in Cut top rate tax
uh Cuts lots of other taxes for the
better off and Promises it's
entrepreneurial Revolution Will
fortunately uh they had a four-year term
including the Falklands War Victory but
a four-year term and the economy had
begun to come good now this trust is
already in mid-term of a parliament so
going in with that kind of ideological
quasi quateng budget which lets big
corporations off a windfall tax would be
a very hard sell unless you know the
economy is seen to come right in time
for the general election so if she goes
down that route I think she needs to
deliver on other things that red vote
War voters care about particularly uh
immigration control particularly you
know coming up with solutions to the
channel dinghy crisis I think a much
tougher approach on Law and Order uh too
there are other policy areas where she
can win plaudits from but it's a very
risky thing for her economically to to
kind of jump from boris's social
democracy if you like to you know
hardcore thatcherite Revival and finally
as a final question to you
um you obviously researched for this
biography of Russia Scenic and I think
you said that you found it hard to find
much to dislike
do you think if you look at some of the
campaign errors you were referring to
it's really seen it just too nice for
politics
yeah
um do you know I thought that at the
time that I was researching um that
biography of Wishy sunak
um I did think that and it was almost
the only thing that I could find that
anyone would say that was critical about
him that he you know he perhaps lacked
the Killer Instincts now you know two
years is a long time that book came out
a couple of years ago and I think we
have seen that he does have the Killer
Instinct but a killer instinct is not
very useful if you're if your prey is
the wrong one and I think what we have
learned is that yes he has a Killer
Instinct but he's not actually targeting
the right to the right prey
um what I just want to pick up finally
on what Paddy was saying about what a
shock it might be if they go full-on
that's right quite quite soon on when
they take over if indeed that's what's
happening I actually think they are
going to do that um I think that quasi
quateng is pretty hard line I think he
doesn't mind whether he's popular or not
which is a novelty given the prime
minister we've we've had the outgoing
prime minister really does want to be
popular I don't think that Mr cuartang
if he ends up being the chancellor cares
about that I think he wants to do what
he regards as the right thing for the
country and I think we're in for a
pretty bumpy and exciting time actually
well with that thank you Isabel and
thank you Patrick
[Music]
thank you